[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation an epic episode today
immersive experiences at the peak
definitely some of the best ones out
there
we have Marie Hillary joining us thank
you so much for going on great to be
here thanks for having me yeah we're
gonna be talking about transformation
through music and Murray four-and-a-half
years ago started mine travel and mine
travel I was grateful enough to get one
of the experiences in Los Angeles we
shared quite the night we shared quite
the night and we have a we have some
really great videos and images to walk
you through what this experience is
actually like and how we can help bring
it to more people around the world it's
just so reflecting so contemplative so
meditative so musical musically tying
tying in to our body and our soul yeah
it's just like it I'm so grateful thank
you so okay so how does one even get
onto this journey yeah
that's a great question one very small
step at a time I mean this really goes
back to when I was five six years old I
started playing music cello when I was
five piano when I was six all my
siblings played there was something that
our you know our mom just was like you
know expose us to music and but by the
time I got to be you know early high
school music became such a vehicle of
expression for me I was a very shy kid
words were not easy for me to come up
with I was difficult to express myself
through words and music really was my
outlet and very quickly I started to
compose my own short songs and tunes at
the piano and when I was in high school
I had a very clear vision that I had
something to say with music and that I
wanted to be a composer that I had my
own thing to say with music not just
perform other composers work as much as
I love
Bach and Chopin and Beethoven and all
the greats
I had my own message at some point to
express through music so it started with
writing the alma mater to my high school
and then I you know then I became a
composer I studied to be a composer at
NYU and that was my training and and
then the rest kind of to go from there I
loved the mother that helped seed the
instruments at a young age yeah this is
a frequent occurrence with parents and
children is that if you've cede them
with tools and resources at young enough
ages they will naturally be able to
figure out what their soul path is but
when we don't have those resources or
tools available to kids then then
sometimes we think oh we've been off in
the wrong ways well essentially you
mentioned that because resources are
sometimes skills they're sometimes
physical resources of course there's you
know resources we get from our parents
but some of them are soft resources
right like emotional resources and
personality resources and I asked my
mother I remember I don't know about
about 10-15 years ago I asked her what
was your eCos in raising us as a parent
as another kind of what what really was
your goal what was what grow view great
question I mean great question because
this is my question that you certainly
don't know the answer to when you're a
kid right so it's an adult conversation
to have with your parent in reflection
of your childhood and it helps frame a
lot of things and I answered that
question without hesitation she didn't
have to think about it was very clear
for her and she said my goal with each
and every one of you and I'm 105 from
the second of five with each and every
one of you was to give you the
confidence to do what you want to do
with your life yes and that just hit me
like a ton of bricks at the time because
I was like yeah because each of my
siblings are remarkable in the each in
their own way and we each do different
things I have a brother that's in
neuroscience I have a brother that's an
Orthodox rabbi I have a brother that's
in alternative energy and solar energy
my sister was a brilliant beautiful
dancer and teacher so II
of us doing our own thing in our own way
but each of us with the confidence that
we can achieve what our dream is and so
it wasn't a cookie cutter thing right
like oh we're all doctors or we're all
lawyers or well right it was like each
and every one of us can figure out what
we want to do and have the confidence to
achieve it to pursue it to execute on it
and that's I think a great gift that she
gave each and every one of us and I'm
super grateful for that and then of
course the actual skills the resources
right say because when you pick up an
instrument at five six years old its
second nature right it's like kids with
these you know with their iPhones today
right where their iPads like you know it
took us a while to figure out what this
gesture was and what you know all these
gestures for them it's second nature
right and so they're kind of going into
their future with inherent skills that
were more learned for us to you know
achieve as adults but that was that's
what music was for me you know when I
sit at the piano when I sit at the cello
these are positions and muscle
formulations that are just so natural
for me so it's a real it's a real
blessing that I that I have that in my
literally in my physicality and in my
brain body connection yeah with such a
good story from your mom ethic from her
I mean just amazing that she was present
that and by the way she was 18 when she
got married had me when she was 22 so
what 22 year old thinks that way let
alone a 30 to 40 to 50 or two year old
62 year old thinks that way like it's
just it's just incredible that she had
the presence to that and you know and
and like many parents she wanted to you
know she wanted to play piano when she
was a kid but my grandparents for
whatever reason didn't offer that to her
and so what she became a parent she gave
us all music kind of that compensatory
thing in a way but in a positive sense
right she's like I couldn't play when I
was a kid I want you to play and she
took lessons side by side with us that's
what was cool yeah we went we went to
the teacher me my older brother at the
time we were you know I was five years
old my brother was eight and you know
she would sit there through our lessons
and then she would take a lesson as well
and we would sit there waiting for her
to take her lesson it was just awesome
yeah I remember that very quickly I
would read my Winnie the Pooh or Sharma
web you know in the other room while she
would get her her lesson yeah yeah Wow I
love ethics that can be applied
universally to give kids the confidence
or the courage that they need to reach
their actualization their peak their
goal their sold blueprint right that I
love universal ethics like that because
universally people can just agree that
that's a really good one how do we give
kids that that's a good one it's a
critical one because we all have great
ideas Allen right we all have ideas that
could be game-changing we all have ideas
that could be disruptive that could be
transformative for other people for
society but how many of us take that
first step how many of us are able to
execute on it and it's not just
resources it's not just money you can
have all the money in the world I know
people that have all the money in the
world and they do not execute on their
own ideas it's self-esteem it's lack of
confidence it's what if I fail like
there's all these fears that bubble up
to the surface and those are natural
fears we all have those fears but what
do you do in the face of that fear right
do you just hear it and listen to it and
cower to it or do you hear it and be
like thank you I appreciate that
I'm gonna keep going right yeah and
that's the difference between those who
achieve and those who those who don't
whatever is on the other side of fear is
the most amazing success story of your
life that's right much absolutely right
stories of your life
so all right that was that was amazing
because of we were a hundred percent on
board with actualizing children into our
world okay we talked about that a lot so
I love that intro to this show okay so
we ended up was four and a half years
ago the start of the theatre kazoos and
why it was NYU and then where did the
whole idea to take the composed music
come into the theaters for these
experiences so I mean if we just back
back up a for managers in terms of the
chronology the story so when I graduated
you know had studying classical
composition from NYU
my first question upon graduation was
how am I going to make any money with
classical music mm-hmm right and people
with my
we from my program they would typically
go into writing jingles
for TV commercials TV scores things like
that and if that's your goal
awesome more power to you it wasn't my
calling at the time and by the today in
today's TV age commercials are kind of
cooler they're more content than they
ever were and more creative than they
ever were but back then I don't think
they were so much so it wasn't my
calling and I said and I would talk to
these composers and they'd be like well
you're working on these commercials
you're making good money went you know
when did you write your first symphony
right and they look at me like I had 12
heads and they'd be like what are you
talking about there's like no time for
that and they've been working for 15
years doing what they do without writing
the music they really want to write
right and I was like oh wow that was a
wake-up call for me right I was like
okay that you can get really caught up
in the deadlines in the money in the
flow of that and then not write the
music you want to write that seemed like
almost a form of existential hell to me
where you're writing music but not what
you want to write what not what you want
to express which is the whole point and
purpose of getting into it in the first
place and that's also what so many
people in the socio-economic political
trap that we live in
absolutely and go through absolutely I
have a sole purpose that is getting
vectored off course because I have to
make money to pay for and and pay for
food that's right and and these are
rational pragmatic reasonable decisions
and choices that we make and we think
that we can figure out how to compensate
for this loss of spirit and soul that we
sacrificed in our deal with the devil
not to put it so dramatically but it is
a it is a somewhat deal with the devil
on some degree but we have to be careful
because suddenly 15 20 years goes by
really quick and then very quickly and
then think about the beautiful composed
right he's that could have been and then
you just you know you can course correct
but how are you aware to course-correct
and will you be too stuck or perceived
to be too stuck to to course-correct
so so I was thank God I got that message
at 22 and but then I was like whoa now
what do I do I you know I have to
support myself and I
so I started teaching kids had a you
know play piano and appreciate music in
music theory but you know that was
getting me I don't know 18,000 a year as
a music teacher you know and I was like
okay this is you know getting me some
food but like there's a lot I want to do
in life I want to see the world I want
to explore I want to create I want to do
things that I need more resources and I
was talking to my older brother at the
time and he was telling my frustration
and trying to figure out my path and he
was working at the NIH the National
Institutes of Health at the time doing
neuroscience research there and he was
one of the first because he worked in
the government facility he was one of
the first to see the internet the
earliest days of the intrud in 1994-1995
and he said Murray have you ever heard
of the Internet uh-huh it's a crazy
question yeah but that actually was a
valid question at some point in history
right so I was like I heard of it what
is it tell me again what is it and he
said I'm coming to New York I'll show
you I'll show you and he comes to New
York and he shows me this obscure there
was no web it was just text databases of
people sharing in his case scientists
and medical researchers sharing it and I
was like well this is this is
interesting and he goes this would be a
game-changer I said yeah I think it's
gonna be game changers connecting so
many thousands of people of course it
would become billions of people right
and we decided to just jump in because
it was such an exciting time such an
early time but such an exciting time and
we just jumped in we created a company
called Earth web and long story short
cut to 1998
we took that company public and we just
had an absolute blast of a ride for
those five six years of building that
company up and and taking it public and
having our Father with us on the
exchange floor the day we went public
and he you know until that point he had
no idea what we did he was like I don't
know what you guys are doing but
whatever good luck I support you you
know I wish you would come into the
family business but okay like you know
you're doing what you're doing you know
kids will be kids and then what was
doing so Earth web began as one of the
premier web shops you know voted by
Wired magazine as like the top where
Consultancy in the country and then we
actually created the like web design and
for web design and but massive
installations you know big big
integrations online we built a new york
stock exchange website the Metropolitan
Museum of Art these massive
infrastructures of web design but also
these these real kind of deep
integrations with back-office legacy
systems so that that kind of thing like
if you remember the you know BMG buy ten
CDs for the price of one you know think
back when we were younger we ported that
all online for through downloads and
integrated it with their you know
fulfillment facilities and just a lot of
legacy enterprise systems with web
interfaces so we were the biggest and
best at doing that and so but then we
realized we wanted to kind of expand
beyond that and since we were text you
know tech people creating stuff for tech
people we we ended up building dice com
the job board the career site which till
today is the largest job site for tech
and and related areas I think dices
dices yeah so yeah so we we you know we
were pioneering moving career and job
placement from literally paper right
from newspapers and magazines and
offline to the web and we pioneered that
and grew that and today it's a you know
quarter of a billion dollar business and
and we're we're fully out of that now
but it continues to thrive is yeah
something that's something that you know
we we built this I'm very proud of you
and your brother or your composing he's
in neuroscience right you're still
working on web companies right right at
the forefront of the era that's that's
great I think that you know the the
reason for that is not that I was a
techie I learned on the job I figured it
out as I went but it was such an
exciting area it was living on that edge
it was as a creative person it was
something that just drew me because of
its potential yeah because of its
possibility the the tech part is the
detail right there's issues and
technical issues and jargon and and
things in every industry but it's music
whether it's technology whatever it is
can learn you can figure that out right
as long as you aren't daunted by it and
you have no limiting belief that oh I'm
not a techie or I'm not this right we
are everything if we want it if you want
to be so I just figured that out and
hired people that were smarter than me
in those areas to figure that out you
know I never wrote a line of code in in
a company that wrote millions of lines
of code right but it was not down about
that it was about what's the vision
where's this going what's the potential
what's the possibility what can people
do with what we build that they can't do
today so that was let's throw us in the
tub back in the timeline so where's dice
and then where did the composing for the
first theater shows happened right so
because I kept the music that decision
when I was 22 to keep the music more
personal I continued to write for others
throughout that whole startup experience
and I had you know a blessing of my
first symphony recorded and performed in
st. Petersburg Russia as an example so
you know again other musicians playing
my work and and you know it was few and
far between but it was enough to kind of
keep me keep me going
I had my visual art my photography and
and work shown in different galleries
again because I didn't have to show up
9:00 to 5:00 for my art right for my
music so I was able to maintain it with
other people performing it or agents and
galleries showing my work I was able to
do that while having my startup and you
know eventually my public company so
that was possible I also had a grand
piano in my office in New York on Park
Avenue Wow and and oh my you know all my
employees at the time kind of you know
if you ask them they remember they you
know I had this grand piano in my office
and at the end of every 16-hour 12 hour
startup day I would just sit at the
piano and I would just play yeah and it
was my way of resetting yes it was my
way of decompressing and processing and
that became my musical ritual yes that
became my musical meditation that became
my way of finding that balance
of resetting and I just did that all the
time and that became my language and
involved to create this experience that
was extemporaneous this improvisation
and it was it was the way I would look
to find material for composed pieces but
it in and of itself became a ritual that
was so valuable to me
I couldn't replace it with anything else
and I had studied meditation I have you
know my journey into the spiritual
realms started when I was 16 you know I
read Siddhartha by Hermann Hesse and
then I was off write read everything I
get my hands on traveled overseas for a
year
lived in monasteries studied Zen
Buddhism studied Vedic traditions I just
took it all in and that world started to
fuse with the classical world and that's
what was being expressed is my
understanding my attempt to understand
the universe through the lens of these
mystical traditions these wisdom
traditions these Eastern philosophies as
well as using classical music training
that I had that was my my language of
expression you know looking at you know
I trained with some of the some of the
greatest minimalist composers and and
those two worlds started to talk to each
other I love that fusion of that
spiritual with the musical and being
able to express it into the kind of
society that we live in bright day in a
way that resonates with people in a way
that and this is kind of where we're
getting at is all the ways that you get
to express what you've learned the
universe through music right to people's
souls meanwhile people are having these
incredible experiences right while
they're listening absolutely how and you
know music has been fused with the
spiritual traditions since you know
since the first flame since man you know
kind of first found you know him/herself
on the on the planet whether it's
shamanic drumming whether it's you know
: response circles all the way to Bach
writing he you know he was a religious
composer he worked for the church he
wrote a cantata every week for services
on Sunday that's why he is such a
prolific amount of work to Beethoven
said that music is the medium to bridge
the divide between the sensual and the
spiritual right he was saying that 200
years ago so there's always been this
thread line right of music spirituality
being you know kind of connected at the
hip if you will and it just continues to
evolve right as society evolves as as
what's important to us involves for me
music is religion a very different kind
of religion right but not totally
secularized but taking the best wisdom
that I could find out there expressing
it through music and using the music
itself the process of creating and
playing music to give the lessons that
are helpful in everyday life right and
there's lots of there's lots of those
lessons available and I we still need a
you know get through all of this
beautiful content that we have and show
people and I also want to talk a bit
about music theory music composition
because that in itself is super
fascinating and complex so let's let's
get to how we got from the tech boom
companies to theater performances of
mine travel and then we'll get to other
experiences so so cut to about five
years ago I decide you know what it's
time I always know new I want to get
back to my music the tech companies and
by that time I had built three four
companies already took one public sold
one sold two I said okay what am I
waiting for right it's never a good time
to make a life change no one would ever
say oh now is the right time to do it
everything's perfect everything's
aligned I have no commitments everything
everything's great by nature of living
you have commitments and distractions
and responsibilities that that could if
you think of him that way could get in
the way of making a significant life
change so moving from doing the tech
stuff to my music full-time was one of
those moments for me and I said I'm
drawing a line in the sand and I'm doing
it if not now when
so I actually first chose to move cities
because New York for me was so
distracting
the energy of New York all my friends
family tech ventures projects coming at
me always a distraction at the at the
waiting totally so I actually was
already spending part time in LA and I
knew I would have to kind of be in my
house playing piano really digging into
the music hours and hours a day so
having that kind of outdoor space and
natural environment was much more
conducive than kind of feeling more
cooped up in New York yeah
so I actually sold my place in New York
because if I kept it you just easily to
come back back but if I sold it there's
no place to come back to yeah so I sold
the apartment which I had for 12 years
by the way and I moved to Los Angeles
and then I said you know if I'm gonna do
this for real it's not just about
composing but now it's about performing
and that's a different level of
execution of yeah yeah it's a very
different level to be able to play well
enough to compose or play well enough to
perform and I said I need to upgrade my
chops right and I said I thought about
athletes right the highest performing
athletes in the world you look at Roger
Federer you look at any of these
incredible athletes they all have
full-time coaches now if you're Roger
Federer what do you need a coach for
you're the best in the world but that's
why these guys are the best in the world
right yeah because they have someone
who's objectively seeing things from a
different vantage point try this try
that accountability accountability is a
big part of it absolutely and so I said
why shouldn't I treat myself like the
best athletes in the world treat
themselves yeah I am a musical athlete
right and so I actually went and got my
original piano coach who trained me in
New York at the time he was living in
Munich I was in Europe I went to visit
him spent a few days with him we caught
up and we decided that he was gonna
relocate to Los Angeles hmm as my
full-time coach Wow and so I literally
airlifted him out of Munich and he was
at a time in his life where he was ready
for a change like that and so I
airlifted him out we got him a visa
sponsored him and moved him
into my house it was not to Los Angeles
only into the guest bedroom of my house
how do you execute that's how you
execute if you want to do it you got to
immerse yourself yeah deeply yeah and so
we would then train hours and hours a
day and it's like going to the it's like
going that for an athlete going to the
gym and just training and doing every
kind of exercise to get your fitness in
the best shape we did the equivalent of
that at the piano and after doing that
for months and months and months and
months
I then realized okay now it's time to
put this out there and see what people
think and all I could do is put the
experience out as I do it on my own
right those countless hours right at the
office playing at the end of the day
which I would also do in my in my own
home I'm gonna just essentially share
that and make people privy to that
personal experience and it had no name
in the years before but I said I must
come up with a name for this experience
so people can relate to it as opposed to
come see Murray Hilary perform
it's not about entertainment totally it
was never about entertainment or
impressing people or performing for
people it was about sharing a very
private experience with people sharing
information that they experience while
they listen to the music that's right
and sharing something that had a
profound impact on me and seeing if
it'll have the same impact on others so
I invited people to my living room to my
home yes and about 40 people came
friends and friends and friends and I
just said this is something I call mind
travel and I came up with that name
literally a week before that and I was
sitting at my dining room table talking
to a friend and I said what is this
experience it's happening in your mind
it's like going on a journey and then
the name mine travel emerged I said
that's the name and so I said come join
me on this musical journey on this mind
travel experience and I took them
through I don't know about a 30 40
minute continuous musical journey and
they'd sit there in your living room you
sat there they're lying down some we're
sitting down some on the couch and we're
you know everywhere in the living room
yeah and afterwards I had a friend of
mine record one by one
a bunch of people who were there in the
other room and the in private their
reaction to it what was the reaction to
the experience and the next day I
watched about 15 of these interviews
yeah and I was brought to tears yes I
was moved I was moved by how moved they
were exactly and I said okay people are
getting it this is a unique experience
you know this is not a concert where I'm
playing a piece and then people clap
that another piece that people clap it
another piece that's held concerts
typically though but I was going after
something different what I was going
after was something experiential where
people opened up yeah it takes time to
open up yeah some people can open up in
a minute
great some people take 20 minutes some
people take an hour so I need to give
the mind the body time to blossom to
open up so if it's constantly stopping
and starting then people are taken out
in and out of the experience and they'll
keep shutting down an opening shutting
opening shutting they'll never get there
so that was the key for me was to and
that was the format that I used and so I
said from the beginning this is gonna be
consistent and authentic with what I do
on my own I'm not gonna try to dumb it
down I'm not gonna try to make it more
commercial I'm not gonna try to do
anything like that if it works it works
if it doesn't it doesn't so that was the
key rule I set for myself from the
beginning this has to be an authentic
experience consistent with what works
for me and if it's not deemed to be
commercial because we live in an a DD
society where people can only watch you
know two minutes of video or whatever
like okay well we're doing something
different here this is a long format
likewise right I mean put your phone
away like this is like we're going in
and unlock people's souls through music
right and this is also to unlock
people's minds through conversation so
absolutely the same absolutely and I
think and people were ready for it you
know people were ready for it and that
was what was most encouraging we're
ready for it you're watching the
interviews the interviews are bringing
tears you're realizing that you need to
take this to the next love right and I
said okay well let's do it so that
livingroom became another small venue
you know the solo house as an example
and I start to do though
and just introduce it to more and more
people and it was all Alan word-of-mouth
people just invited people I never until
today
I've never advertised that I've never
kind of taken out any campaign it's all
been word-of-mouth and eventually to to
bring it to theaters with gorgeous
Steinway pianos and then bringing my
visuals into it
so that people can see what they hear in
the music right and and you know some
people are more visual than others some
people like to close their eyes and just
take it in other people visuals are very
helpful so I kind of create this fully
immersive multimedia experience which
we've done it theaters and I've had the
you know pleasure and privilege of
bringing it to theaters from Lincoln
Center in New York to the ACE Theatre in
downtown LA and many places in 212 so
we're on we let's throw up some of those
theater images onto the part of the
stream I love this this looks so
beautiful
so here you see you know of course it's
me at the piano and you see this
backdrop which a 40 foot backdrop with
the constellations which if you were to
be in the theater or watch the video at
a another date then you would start to
see the music there's actually a
microphone in the piano that moves and
directs the images so it's generated
dynamically there's software algorithms
in the in my visual software and these
constellations start to warp and move
and the vibration of the piano the music
of the piano actually starts to affect
what's on the screen and the idea here
is that you know there's a fundamental
philosophy that vibrations whether it's
music whether it's our words
impacts our reality yeah so this is
representing our reality of the universe
around us and so we are literally
creators we are the ones dictating how
everything around us looks and is
created and that's what I was
artistically showing right as I play the
universe is getting sculpted to to what
I am creating and that was the mess
that I was attempting to send at this
particular concert and of course many
many many concerts after this I love how
you went and took the visual and had the
algorithms that would change through the
music changed the visuals well that's
the key that ended up becoming a new age
of immersive experience because he used
to just be the instrument now it's the
instrument and the visual so you're
adding a whole new layer to them well
the key is that if I'm playing if I'm
playing extemporaneously right I'm
improvising so each time it's different
if the visual is the same okay look it
works it's you know I get it but what if
the visuals are also changing so the
whole thing is different each time and
the whole thing is integrated each time
and that has such a purity to it and
just such an impact to it as well I'm
glad that you went and did theater shows
and then you were like hey doing this in
theaters is one thing and I'm doing this
on the beach right is another that's
that was the second evolution second
step evolution so here you see an
orchestra playing the work as well so
I've collaborated with some of the
finest musicians in Los Angeles in New
York and other cities and it's just
amazing to just have that kind of power
to play with these this caliber of
musicians you the best in the world that
we're playing with you see the visuals
there again the visuals are dancing to
the music literally dancing to the music
and you have all of the some of the best
in the world on musicians that are
collaborating with you meanwhile the
visuals are going on this but then this
is so much interestingly different than
when you go out into Ocean Beach right
or Venice so yeah so why don't you yeah
walk us well actually we have a cool
video too to play of yeah let's show
people the experience and then we could
talk about it yeah let's do that
cool
what do you feel like when you're free
what if you could love the way you want
to
[Music]
what gives you hope
you
what does strength really look like
[Music]
what kind of world do you want to create
[Music]
what if your greatest self is only a
moment away
[Music]
what is
[Music]
Wow
there's so many things to bring up there
first thing was the bass clef I really
loved your logo how it's a new bass clef
it's the reflection it's the heart yes
and then there's also the amazingness of
being there at a sunset in nature
sharing an experience with other people
on a sandy beach with fresh air from the
ocean coming in you can walk through the
water the ocean water you know there you
are the drone view showed so many people
they're having an amazing time
Wow and the reason why we went there
right there's a everything is purposeful
with this experience so nature is such
an inspiration right for me as an artist
and for each of us as just as human
beings yes right nature is such an
inspiration so I figured if I can bring
the audience to nature yes right half
the job is done for me before I play
well yeah so and it's just so inspiring
right and your imagination just goes and
it's just so healing to be by the ocean
of course especially at sunset it's just
such a powerful time of transition of
the light from light through dark and we
go into the dark right right so it's
this incredible time of creativity and
so I bring the audience there but then I
shift them from being audience members
right again I'm not entertaining them
right that's not what I'm there for
yes I'm there to facilitate and lead
them on a journey yes so they're able to
find freedom in the experience meaning
they can lie on their blanket they can
sit in their chair or they can get up
and they can walk the beach for hundreds
of feet anywhere they want because
they're all wearing these headphones so
why are they wearing headphones I mean I
can have these huge speakers but it
never sounds great at the beach the
acoustics are not great the headphones
provide a great acoustic experience
where everyone essentially has a front
row seat seat yeah no matter where they
are and then there's something else
magical happens out when you put
headphones on even if you're on your own
you're on the subway you're in you know
you're going for a walk you're on a hike
wherever you are you immediately go into
this internal frame this internal state
but now what happens when you're with
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
other people and you're having your
internal state your alone time your
alone time and then you look around
while you're having your internal moment
and you're forgetting about the world
and you see hundreds of other people
having the same alone time the same
intimate moment the same individual
moment yeah that you are collectively
there's an experiential shift that
happens in that moment for you if
something clicks and you get you get the
lesson that we are each profoundly
powerful individuals in a collective
power that can't be matched and the two
are equal and integrated and the second
you get that I think you get a big part
of the human experience because too
often we think we're alone which
translates into loneliness right
loneliness is just the interpretation of
an alone state that's all it's a
psychological interpretation of it right
and so you get this integration of the
whole of the individual parts coming
together as a whole and you feel that
and the music is the space this is what
facilitates that just in the same way
that music right is composed of
individual notes that make up a
composition we are individual notes
making up a human symphony information
so that's that's the that's what's being
communicated through the experience
right and then people are standing by
the water they're up to their knees and
the ocean with the music playing in the
headphones it's it's just absolutely
ecstatic yeah yeah it's really cool I
love how just you you've had the
foresight to realize to bring it out of
the theater into nature and then when
you get to nature you strap people into
the headphones because then they're
having this inward experience with a
front-row seat with the acoustics and
then the other thing that you know like
we have this vision with filling sports
stadiums during their unused time for
the thousands of curious intellectual
sharing the experience of mind expansion
that this is the same thing that when
you're watching this at home it's great
but when you're watching it in a stadium
where thousands of other people that is
that's the experience when
mind traveling with hundreds of other
people that are also going through this
process of this inward reflection in
this symphony of notes that we're all
beautifully similar and different and
we're all part of we're all on this
color wheel of different colors that are
building different things end of the
world absolutely I love it and so okay
so that's I love how you took it from
there right and then you were like I
know what the next step next step yes
I'm looking to immerse people
okay let's really immerse them yes what
could be more immersive than taking the
audience and putting them inside of
water yeah and actually experiencing it
in water and so we then did some beta
testing and now we take over an Olympic
pool and we placed the audience floating
weightlessly with poodles supporting
their knees and back by the way one of
the best moments of my life was when I
actually clicked buy on Amazon for 400
pool noodles yeah 400 pool noodles if
you ever find yourself doing that you
know life is good like you've made it if
you're 400 pool noodles on earth anyway
in it for the long haul it's right
you're committed you're committed one
way or the other you're committed or
just and just to yeah it just to you
know to this is the same one that we
were yes yeah and this is which one in
LA again this is at Culver City at the
place called the plunge it's a outdoor
Olympic pool apply the plunge a plunge
at in LA Olympic sized swimming pool and
so what is you're wearing wetsuits yeah
they're also using pool noodles that's
right and then you have you know in the
bottom right corner yes the Murray set
up on that's my piano on the piano yeah
and then what you get is you get a bunch
of really powerful underwater speakers
yeah there's a massive network of
underwater speakers you can see with
those wires there because headphones you
know they they're not waterproof and and
even if even if they were you wouldn't
get a deep of an experience because with
the underwater speakers you first of all
you hear it once your once your head
goes back and your float an underwater
sound opens up to you but you also feel
it down and you
body right so vibrations of the sound
waves just going through the water it's
eerie right through your soul it's so
amazing and we are cavities right where
we're instruments we have we have hollow
empty parts of us that resonate and
vibrate and them and the and the musical
frequencies go through the water water
is a more efficient conductor than air
of sound and music 4.3 times more
efficient and so you are part of the
vibration literally you are you are part
of it and you're sharing that with 200
other people you know floating with you
and then after they float for the first
half the second half as you remember
people are free moving swimming dancing
underwater in this beautiful childlike
playfulness which you know we all of us
you know we forget to too often how to
be playful and childlike and this opens
up that space for them yeah yeah so the
first the first half like this where
you're you know laying down and you're
kind of you know your feet are up on the
safety right a string that that floats
and then you have your you know you're
just laying there really just reflecting
meditative with all of this amazing
decompression of your back and spine
with the water
yeah but then also the vibration of the
music and it's just gorgeous hearing the
piano through underwater speakers and
then think you're on and then during the
second half of the session this part I
found really fascinating when everyone's
out doing their thing with swimming some
go really deep in the water which
enables them to better hear the music I
I personally enjoyed basically going
right up to one of the water speakers
underwater yes it is basically being
right next to it and just listening to
it right it's just like you can
literally caress it and just have those
vibrations like it's just incredible
really true I do the same yeah I feel
kind of at times I felt kind of selfish
right crap I'm blocking but it goes
right through you the next person and so
this is that was Olympic sized pool yeah
this is a little smaller this is a step
yeah a little smaller only a 75 foot
pool and in New York and we
and you know 50 New Yorkers in this case
go through it and it was just gorgeous
to watch it's a beautiful setting but
just beautiful what how people just
literally dropped in to to have the
experience and you see all the speakers
and there yeah let's play the video that
we have that shows the the beauty of
what this little underwater underwater
experience
[Music]
right my travel underwater yeah so there
was so many there's so much / fun to be
there but one of the one that caught me
most we were talking about was it brings
you back to the womb yeah shamanic
baptism losing sense of time right I
hear that all the time all those all the
time and I mean it's very powerful water
is life
you know water is life and so to be in
it with so many others feeling it it's
just something you can only experience
when you're in there yeah yeah I'm I'm
so excited we are gonna be let's let's
aim to open up more of these across the
world really as quickly as possible
because these do just bring community
and love and light together
okay so that was underwater and then
let's go to some of the photos of these
are easier to do these are on this the
silent hikes so so this is this is kind
of like you go to a beautiful place like
Lands End or the Golden Gate Bridge here
in San Francisco and see that now now
we're talking like oh there's no pool
required there's no wetsuits required I
just need a forest area for it or ocean
and then you bring this this this tub
this case of headphones and then you can
control it via music that you're already
composed on your phone yeah right so I
use a recording from one of my live
concerts so it is a live recording and
then I curate the music to the setting
and I use several different pieces in
and out based on you know the the hike
and I called a silent hike because we're
all wearing the headphones and there's a
no speaking rule that we have so that
it's a very intentional very deliberate
experience it's kind of like a modern
take on walking meditation yep so for
you know those in your audience who
meditate walking meditation as a whole
yeah that's that dogs amazing I mean
dogs are already enlightened beings yeah
you know they're they're playing along
and be like okay I'll do this too but ya
know the dogs actually love it and this
this dog owner put put her headphones on
the dog and the dog chilled with it the
whole time it was pretty
amazing so you know we'd go to beautiful
settings and here we're introducing more
movement into the experience right so
we're hiking for two to three hours
we're walking miles some of them are
challenging some of them are easier and
they're beautiful vistas but not just
beautiful nature vistas like we do here
at Lands End or an ass fan in the
mountains but there are also cityscapes
it's important to bring this to people
in urban environments and give them this
experience so we did it in New York City
right and one of the busiest cities in
the world we brought it and took people
across the Brooklyn Bridge we took
people across the Williamsburg Bridge we
took people through Central Park for
seven miles Wow and we get a hundred
plus people at these events and
everyone's dropped in everyone's silent
you know what it's like to walk through
New York City streets with over a
hundred New Yorkers silently every
demographic you have Wall Street guys
with their suits you have kids you have
ever you know seniors you have everyone
they are represented because it's New
York City and everyone is together in
this beautiful field of kind of like a
school of fish you know going through
the ocean of the city I mean it's just
beautiful to experience and be a part of
so we're doing these now in six
different cities
you know we've got them regularly in San
Francisco Los Angeles Santa Barbara San
Diego and Aspen in New York and we're
gonna continue to expand it from there
and we this experience because I'm not
playing live I'm able to bring
volunteers and city leaders and I'm
training city leaders so that I give
them the equipment I train them in the
format I give them the music and explain
how they do it how to do it and then
they can lead them on a monthly or
whatever basis you know without me
having to be there because unfortunately
I haven't figured out how to be lawyers
yeah yet yet
I love that this is scalable then in
that sense that you found a method that
is immediately scalable and there are
people across all these cities around
the world that would love to conduct
attorneys for people yeah you've nailed
it with this so okay so then we
transition also to these different
experiences across countries like
special experiences at Burning Man
you did a David Bowie O'Brien museum
experience yes so these you know these
are kind of site-specific installations
and activations that I've done you know
Burning Man is such a special place of
course and it's just a profound
environment so when I brought my travel
there we did two special things this the
picture you see here this is actually a
moving concert on an art car yes where
my piano my keyboard is strapped to the
front of this art car yes and we're
actually driving moving through the
playa yeah
and there's not just these people on the
on the car but if you were to you know
if we had a picture here you'd see 70
additional bicycles behind the car with
people wearing headphones
yeah yeah and and and everyone is moving
through the playa together taking in the
experience looking at the artwork
looking at all the other people they're
looking at you know the view and they
have the mind travel and live
performance on this moving stage right
and you have 70 plus cyclists as the
participants of this experience it was
just incredibly profound with the wind
storms coming through and the you know
the elements all around us just
beautiful and of course we brought it to
the temple each night there which you
know for those who are familiar the
temple you know the profound nature of
it the sacred nature of it for those who
don't it's really a very very holy place
for human reflection and contemplation
and so we bring it there each night at
Burning Man and you have this with
throughout these experiences that we've
listed with underwater or the beach or
the hikes or the special experiences it
all ties into this earth energy these
earth elements right that you were
talking about it earlier with how we're
all connected through water and yes
being such a holy thing yet you're being
such a holy thing I'm really happy that
you have that strong tie to life force
absolutely and I and I think if you look
at what people are searching for today
and I just speak from my own experience
right I mean I grew up with very
institutionalized religion and I think
you know many of us have
and something about it doesn't strike
you know to the center of what we're
looking for it provides some ritual but
maybe the meaning we're looking for is a
bit elusive or even the ritual sometimes
seem outdated and so in kind of more of
an open context in more of a universal
context in more of a secularized context
where science is brought in where
experiences are brought in can we be
more proactive can we be more deliberate
in the rituals that we want to create in
our lives but we don't just want to do
them on our own at home we want to
actually have rituals that were able to
share in community with like-minded in
others and so that's really what this is
becoming in that way where it's these
rituals that were able to do over and
over again they're their purification
rituals like the underwater experience
where you leave the water different than
when you entered it yeah yep right
that's what's happening and so the and
music having you know music being the
universal true universal human language
right I've played mine travel I've
brought it to dozens of cities dozens of
countries or Africa the reaction element
is the same yeah whether I was in Dubai
whether I was in Istanbul where there
was in Berlin whether I was in London
New York San Francisco Tel Aviv
Jerusalem I've played in all these
places to audiences and the reaction is
the same the universal language of music
it's the same reaction of love it's
human experience it doesn't matter what
your label is it's a human experience
and that overrides everything it also
under IDEs everything it's it's both so
that that to me is the magic of this and
the blessing of the journey for me and I
think also that your cific style of
music of classical music is what makes
it so universal because sometimes if you
have the heavy metal or the country or
what a hip-hop that won't resonate
across and that's that's more genre
specific and that's more conditioning
experience specific when I'm bringing to
it is something is something a bit meta
from all that musically absolutely and
then I want to
just come to an end on this I think is
so profound this is the future of
everything that we're doing as a society
seems to be going towards experiences
immersive experiences I'm my life is now
becoming experience to experience to
experience to experience and that's my
life is a timeline of experiences and
you are I think at the forefront of
mazing immersive experiences this is it
transcends time it moves you through the
most reflective and contemplative states
possible meditative States possible
gives you the musical The Sound Energy
edge I love all of that now I want to
see what where where you how you feel
about this because to newbies like
myself and some other people that may be
watching you know we were listening to
what you were playing there was dun dun
dun you're really going through this
sort of how did you howdy how does one
compose where does the when you look at
a musical chart writes a chart is it
where the bar where the Margaret or the
bars alright staff staff as we're staff
in the bar how do you decide you know to
put the note low to put the note high or
hold the note for a couple beats or to
do a couple quickly right how do you
figure that out how does one graph out
the soul music right so for me when I'm
at the piano and I'm composing live I'm
doing a real-time composition at the
piano there's none of that
all that dissolves and disappears and
it's just about how intimate and close
can I get with the vibrations of the
music and it's about getting out of my
own way
getting the thought out of the way so
it's not like okay if I'm in this
harmony and this key and there's a you
know that's all out all that is built
into my muscle memory all that's built
in to my musical language the same way
that you have fluency in English and
perhaps other languages you don't think
about the words when you structure them
together do you you just say them so
that's what's happening with me
musically
I'm just emotive mem I'm expressing them
I'm really I'm storytelling yeah at the
end of the day yes in the same way that
you've story tell with words into
sentences into into paragraphs at etc
I'm storytelling with musical letters
words sentences and albeit an abstract
storytelling so I'm not thinking a
specific storyline like we would in in
you know verbally I'm thinking of
something abstract it's an abstract
message it's abstract storytelling and
that's about getting out of my own way
consciously and dropping into some other
consciousness state right it's not a
flow State you're right there in a deep
flow and improvisation yes right it's
you've got the the prefrontal cortex
who's constantly trying to executive lis
order everything you've gotten that
completely out of the way so that way
you can just drop in with your soul into
the music and then it's all improv then
you're composing improvisationally
that's right and I'm and I'm expressing
this story and hopefully if I'm if I'm
doing my job I'm opening up right it's a
process of successively opening up
meaning and opening up my heart opening
up this vulnerability space to let
people in to my hurt to let people into
my joy to let people into my emotional
state and hopefully even further into
something even deeper spiritually and if
I can do that successfully then you
don't have to be the one playing to
achieve that yeah you can just be in the
field and feel the same exact thing that
I'm feeling and so that's if all the
ingredients line up that's the magic
that's the possible magic although I'm
so so grateful to have you on the show
and building this into the world I want
to have as many people as possible try
this you know mind travel calm the link
is in the bio sign up in la Santa
Barbara SF New York where else where
were you saying earlier Aspen yeah so
there's all these different places to
you go sign up for yes yay go yes San
Diego the silent the silent hikes sound
hikes and life and live experiences in
life and
and then you soon will get more Olympic
pools filled with my travel as well and
get more people immersed in that we
usually we're kind of little a little a
little over time we like to ask a couple
questions on the show around can we get
them quick in okay
all right how about out what do you
thinks the most beautiful thing in the
world oh wow every moment has infinite
amount of beauty that we can see and
it's available all the time it's
available all the time unfortunately we
tend to not see it and we tend to see
negative we tend to see the downside but
the exercise of opening up every single
moment I mean I once sat in the park and
found myself mesmerised by little flies
flying around in a swarm I just watch
them for about 20 it's yeah and it was
those beautiful thing trying to figure
out what was happening with them and
just experiencing them so really what
I'm saying is that being is the most
beautiful thing I think that exists yeah
yeah I'm sorry I was free but being is
the most beautiful thing that exists and
then you can find an unlimited amount of
beauty in every single moment yeah I I
think we're attaining that ability to do
that over your life and is one of the
most underrepresented on absolute skills
that we desperately absolutely better
and and don't confuse being I'm sorry
don't get these beauty with pretty right
a lot of things are pretty but beauty
transcends pretty beauty is about
accepting understanding and seeing the
full spectrum right of the love life
experience of what's happening which
includes the ugly which includes the
sorrowful which includes into this
bittersweet agree wrapper and feeling
that fully and absorbing that into your
soul on the deepest level that's beauty
yeah yeah we have our way of a running
joke where Ron says that I could see the
beauty in a pie
with [ __ ] you can you know cuz he we
say that I see flies that need you can
to poopin that's part of absolutely part
of the ecosystem you can yeah well that
day we got pepper-sprayed do you know
well it's good to get pepper spray
pieces right it's hard to see the beauty
when it affects you negatively but if
you get out of that and you get really
on the on the street and it was someone
like half a block away that was upset at
someone else and started pepper spraying
them we were watching and then we didn't
you know think about it so much to like
have to go run away as fast possible but
anyway some of the particles from the
pepper spray came and hit oh my gosh and
I just couldn't see for the longest time
and then everyone's like how do you feel
how it's like yeah it's good to get
pepper sprayed you know you that's right
you get to you know fully feel your body
feel how blessing it is to actually have
have your have your sight yes absolutely
yeah Wow
let's get people signed up for mind
travel let's give them experience in
this Marie thank you for building thank
you our world
thank you we love you so much you too
Thank You Alan what a pleasure thank you
Ron yeah thank you Ron it's they're
directing and producing everyone give us
a comment below let us know your
thoughts about mind travel in these
transformative experiences also go check
out mine travel get yourself signed up
for an experience and make sure to go
and create go and build go and manifest
your destiny into the world follow that
soul blueprint and execute baby thank
you for tuning in much love everyone and
we'll see you soon
[Music]